hey guys I'm Ryan right hey guys I'm Sal
all right um so sorry for God who sent
us this video but I tweeted send us the
most disturbing video you can find on
YouTube and someone sent in top 5
weirdest videos on the Internet
I'm hoping these are really disturbing
ice set you salad fingers in there maybe
I wanted Sally to be here because let's
face it what is funnier than grossing
out a woman it's pretty simple I just
show them my biggest guy cry that is
funnier yeah it's usually a one-two
combo i gross the girl out I show her my
penis and then she starts laughing and
then she and then I start crying number
five here we go
you're 2571 at video conceits that was
found a pyro on the ruins of certain
blue planet we're about to witness will
not be the contents of the four
mentioned cassette this is an entirely
different recording scary
you
like when I was preview
Oh
Oh
all right I hope the last three are
better no but that was creepy yeah these
are creepy I want them I want these to
be like [ __ ] in your face you know
I'm gonna be like oh my god should have
watched that okay how do you still do
that hand thing I heard you're doing the
hand thing today
God what is that I love it
ah good videos play with them do the
hand thing called a fridge work
george'll be heads we're doing on a city
made earlier
ah good ah ah
yeah I look like a snuff movie the
transitions are serious these
transitions are scared
looks so real that was pretty
I'm looking at it but I feel bad cuz
it's a person this is uber can you feel
ready to pop up okay I feel like we just
stepped into the mind of a serial killer
now when you see movies that are like
quick fast images of like someone's mind
or some pass or like you you find like
some like eight millimeter footage of
some [ __ ] and you're like it's a [ __ ]
horror movie that's what that reminded
me of that was pretty [ __ ] up
obviously the second one was the most
disturbing
there's no one there and I'm gonna be
terrified I'm sure it was fake that
second one but it was really well done
yeah I know I know it's fake but those
what if it wasn't you wouldn't ya know
is brilliant like I don't I wonder how
they film that exactly just getting the
hands through the walls and then making
the hand creatures must have been visual
effects in my son have been like a bunch
of real people I don't know yeah the
other ones are just like [ __ ] weird
and creepy
yeah but now like with just any editing
system you didn't make anything with
creepy yeah like I like weird and creepy
when it's like I can tell there's
something behind this yeah but you know
the other ones like I don't like it when
I don't have no idea how or why anyone
would do that
yeah the first ones I was like wow those
bother me so much it seemed like a bad
acid trip the whole time normally we
review these videos but not much content
to work off of here yeah if you guys are
gonna do the channel you can subscribe
to the real rejects you can check out
salamander Sally's channel a lot of
variety on there you can follow us on
Facebook Instagram and Twitter where if
we get enough followers piranha a
placement for things such as apples
apples are great they're nutritious good
in fiber have some vitamin stuff in
there whatever
let's not forget that apples are also
evil Eve ate the apple because she was
tempted by a snake understandable and
then Adam ate the Apple and then now
we're all [ __ ] because they had a
[ __ ] Apple Bob hate being human
apples